à l'est la situation politique en israël
on en parle ce matin avec claude
blanchemaison notre expert en relations
internationales c'est l'édito
diplomatique de la matinale
[Musique]
bonjour que le blanchemaison bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être en direct avec
nous dans la matinale d'air france est
ce que les décisions prises par la
knesset ce nouveau délai de sept jours
sont surprenantes ou pas écoutez nous
parlera pas pas très surprenant
puisqu'ils à la knesset se jouer l'acte
2 du processus politique en cours en
israël
l'actos un c'était le suspense de
mercredi dernier est ce que monsieur
yaïr lapid alerte allait réussir ou pas
à constituer un gouvernement de
coalition qu'il appelle lui gouvernement
d'union nationale et finalement on a eu
la réponse très tardivement à 23h40
mercredi donc allait vraiment à la
dernière minute hier à la knesset
c'était à un point un peu fort mal
bravo 620 qui se déroulait puisque la
knesset pro d acte du fait que monsieur
vieillir lapide avait bien réuni les
signatures de huit partis qui
théoriquement lui donnent une majorité
de 61 de soixante et une voix au
parlement et devait décider la knesset
devait décider quel jour aurait lieu le
vote de confiance
elle aurait pu décider que ça lieu tout
de suite mais comme prévu le président
yariv levin a décidé que ça aurait lieu
sept jours plus tard cela n'est pas
surprenant puisque c'est ce que demande
et monsieur netanyahou et qu'ils
appartiennent au même parti le likoud
par conséquent c'est une sorte de délai
de réflexion
ils ont le fond tout ce qu'on prend dans
une démocratie qui est totalement
parlementaire parlement qui a qu'à tous
les pouvoirs et donc ceci devient
évidemment dans les circonstances
actuelles en israël une semaine de tous
les dangers
alors selon le gouvernement de selon
vous le gouvernement de monsieur l'epide
obtiendra-t-il la majorité
et monsieur netanyahou est en embuscade
et les propos qu'il a tenus montre bien
qu'il fera tout pendant sept jours pour
empêcher monsieur lapide d'obtenir cette
majorité
alors il traite ce gouvernement de
gouvernement dangereux du gouvernement
de droite de gouvernement fait de bric
et de broc et il ne se cache pas de sa
volonté de l'empêcher de gouverner
et si par hasard ils étaient ils étaient
confirmés il était élu d'ici le 7
ici le sait didier d'ici sept jours eh
bien il s'emploierait évidemment à le
faire à le faire tomber à le à le
censurer
il a été obligé de se défendre hier
c'est netanyahu en disant qu' évidemment
ils n'avaient pas la violence que
personne ne pouvait appeler à la
violence mais que quand c'était monsieur
lapide qui parlait on accepter ces
propos et quand c'était lui on
l'accusait d'appeler à la violence donc
on voit que le climat est extrêmement
tendue par ailleurs il y à l'appel d'un
groupe de rabah intégristes qui demande
à ce que la confiance ne soit pas votée
des parties très départ titre hyper
religieux et on voit bien que évidemment
cette coalition est fragile et
vulnérable puisque il y a huit partis de
droite dont trois de droit par dont deux
de gauche du centre et puis le parti
raam qui est un parti d'arabes
conservateur israélien
donc monsieur netanyahou a très
clairement s'employer pendant cette
semaine a essayé de débaucher de
dissocier les éléments de cette
coalition y arrivera-t-il ça n'est pas
sûr parce que il ya un vent de
changement il ya un vent de changement
en israël que voit bien que
le chef des services de sécurité
intérieure cas les désordres
il a appelé à la raison la marche des
drapeaux qui devait avoir lieu jeudi est
en principe n'a pas lieu
mais les l'extrême droite va sans doute
essayer de la de la maintenir et donc
jeudi sur un rang sans doute le jour de
l'épreuve de vérité
si la journée se passe dans le calme il
est possible que ce gouvernement
obtiennent finalement son investiture et
cette nouvelle coalition claude
mettra-t-elle fin à la crise politique
en israël
dans l'immédiat oui parce que la crise
politique elle dure depuis deux ans
depuis deux ans il ya eu quatre
élections si ce gouvernement n'a pas la
confiance d'ici lundi prochain il y aura
une cinquième élection est en effet
c'est ce que monsieur netanyahou
souhaite puisqu'il continuera à gérer
les affaires du pays avec à la tête d'un
gouvernement intérimaire
mais au bout de deux ans il serait
souhaitable sans doute que l'espagne se
dote d'un gouvernement qui ne soit pas
uniquement intérimaire et que en effet
après tout ça n'est pas absurde que dans
une situation aussi complexe que celle
d'israël il ya un gouvernement d'union
nationale qui représente à la fois des
mouvements de droite et des mouvements
de gauche qui a un noyau centriste qui
est important puisque c'est monsieur
lapide qui a joué le formateur du
gouvernement même si ce n'est pas lui
qui sera premier ministre pendant les
deux premières années il ne le sera
qu'en suite après que naftali bennett et
le brésil gouvernement pendant les deux
premières années
et puis cette expérience unique d'avoir
un parti arabe israélien membres de la
coalition et il est il est donc probable
que ceux ci apportera un certain nombre
d'idées nouvelles et que sa mère à ce
gouvernement à mettre en oeuvre des
politiques nouvelles
cela dit il est probable qu'ils ne
durera pas très longtemps parce que en
effet il sera attaqué de toute part et
notamment par le diko y met
si beaucoup claude pour toutes ces
explications c'est l édito diplomatique
de la matinale